you know burgerfeld the court said no we  know better than you guys do and now  every state must  uh  must sanction and permit gay marriage  um i think that decision was clearly  wrong when it was decided  um  it was the court overreaching  imagine that applied to interracial  marriage listen  it's not that i'm against interracial  marriage it's that the supreme court  cannot decide that for the states states  must be allowed to determine do they  want to allow interracial marriages or  not that's the right way to do it and if  you extrapolate out from this idea of  leave everything to the states  black folks might still be enslaved in  some states in the south i mean maybe  not today but certainly into the early  1900s that's for damn sure  civil rights and liberties are not  states rights issues they are guaranteed  by the constitution you don't put rights  up to a vote